do I look too high here yes on the seat
are you intoxicated no no they're around
I'm six five to thirty and I'm sleeping
the double bed hello Peter King can I
have a sandwich I want a sandwich
I am the Rob Gronkowski of swearing okay
his body has been absolutely beaten to
death Kamini there's no [ __ ] rumors
off with that doublespeak
I'm concerned that if you get too
comfortable using that kind of language
into a microphone it's gonna come out
you watch this around oh it's broken
what have you wearing because I like it
I would kill for a yellow Gatorade
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching see you later say
peace out homies he's out homies there
we go
no the microphones are always on
unfortunately you cannot escape them
some of the fun that we had and it was
we were kind of getting delirious it was
a little hot it was a little hot see
just to peel back the curtain just for a
second to shield us from the Arizona Sun
they use these giant sheets that create
an oven effect yeah so we don't get
baked by the Sun we get baked by the
heat that is generated by the portable
oven that is created to shield us from
the Sun either way we get baked not in
that way we get we get you love that but
it was fun it was fun but I'm very glad
to be home there it truly is no place
like home Chris yes I'm glad that it's
not 85 degrees right now it was hot and
again to what you said the sheets there
they trapped the heat in and then we got
these big production TV lights to that
add to it I felt like I was getting a
tan out there without even being in the
Sun yeah guess what neither of us got
one we got a full hour of pro football
talk live coming at you right now
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports